nous appelons tous ces républicains qui
sont hostiles à cette réforme des
retraites de d'en tirer toutes les
conséquences et de rejoindre tous ceux
qui votent en faveur de cette notion de
censure je leur dis simplement comme
quelqu'un qui ne vient pas de la droite
comme un responsable politique qui
essaye de chercher un peu de dignité un
peu de cohérence est-ce que vous voulez
ajouter de la difficulté la difficulté
ce que vous voulez jouer l'instabilité
j'ai pris du temps pour y penser pas le
faire à la légère et oui je voterai la
motion de censure portée par Charles de
Courson la motion transpartisane je ne
voterai pas la motion du rassemblement
national c'est une évidence et je trouve
ça dommage que certains préfèrent être
des francs-tireurs que des responsables
politiques au sens plan du terme nous
serons une bonne dizaine voire une
quinzaine à soutenir ces notions je suis
pas certain que tout le monde ira au
vote des deux motions mais moi par
cohérence puisque aujourd'hui mon seul
maître mot c'est aussi la cohérence si
on en voit une
notamment celle de l'iode qui est
composé à la fois de députés d'extrême
gauche je vois pas pourquoi je voterai
pas celle de l'extrême droite qui est
identique il y a aussi une tradition à
droite de comprendre qu'on ne peut pas
gouverner contre le peuple d'autres
premiers ministres d'autres présidents
de droite de cette obédience politique
avait compris cela et ça a été l'Ajax
je pense à Dominique de Villepin
notamment parce que vous vous voterez la
motion de censure du rassemblement
national ouais je vous l'ai dit tout à
l'heure des mois de janvier je dis
toutes l'émotion de censure pourquoi ils
ont le courage de voter pour la motion
de censure bien évidemment si demain il
y a des solutions il n'y aura pas de
candidat RN en face des députés LR qui
ont voté la motion je veux insister sur
la gravité de cet instant
notre décision de déposer une motion de
censure n'a pas été prise à la légère
notez gros vous avez mis en garde contre
la tentation de passage en force nous
assumons la responsabilité sur le texte
mais qu'on ne dise pas qu'il n'y a pas
eu de cheminement démocratique il y a eu
un cheminement démocratique de plusieurs
mois à un moment donné vient le temps de
la décision la décision c'est
aujourd'hui avec cette motion de censure
la dernière réponse sur votre dispositif
carrière longue qui tire à pile ou face
la durée de cotisations de ceux qui ont
commencé tôt 43 ans 44 ans on ne
comprend pas mais bien loin du juste
prix c'est à la roue de l'infortune que
vous jouez s'il n'y a pas eu de votre
sur l'article 7 c'est parce que
systématiquement méthodiquement et
volontairement la France insoumise a
fait obstruction pendant les débats
interventions au pas de course ce matin
pour les forces de l'ordre
sur cette rocade à l'entrée de Rennes
les gendarmes mobiles démontent ce
barrage Manu military nous députés du
rassemblement
nous voterons toutes l'émotion de
censure car nous ne craindrons jamais
les urnes et sommes prêts à y retourner
le jeu du chat et de la souris entre
manifestants et forces de l'ordre à
continuer toute la matinée autour de la
capitale bretonne certains
automobilistes ont passé des heures dans
leur voiture plutôt patiemment 6 ans de
ce chaos est porté disparu Emmanuel
Macron se cache depuis des semaines
derrière ses fusibles il communique
uniquement par correspondance la
question que les gens se posent à qui
nous regardent c'est mais où est
Emmanuel Macron il y a il faut peut-être
pas diffuser une alerte enlèvement oui
Emmanuel Macron fait honte à la France
donc le président de la République pour
dire quoi bah écoutez s'il n'a rien à
dire qu'il s'en aille
49,3.000 abonnés hier enfin de journée
le compte Instagram d'Élisabeth borne
affiché ce nombre symbolique de
followers il ne s'agit pas d'une
coïncidence mais d'une blague d'un
internaute qui a déboursé quelques euros
pour acheter des abonnés à la première
ministre nous ne vanterons donc pas
l'émotion de censure
nous laisserons pas entraînés par une
extrême gauche qui est assume de vouloir
détruire les institutions de la
Cinquième République l'équipe de
communication d'Elisabeth borne supprime
ses nouveaux followers pour effacer la
référence à l'article 49-3 aujourd'hui
le compte de la première ministre privée
il faut demander pour s'abonner
la majorité requise n'étant pas atteinte
la motion de censure n'est pas adoptée